who do you think is the greatest player
of all time you've talked in from
different angles on this uh Magnus
Carlos and Gary kasparo Bobby Fischer
many others can can you make the case
for each
um can you make the case for you oh no I
mean I can't make the case for me to be
serious I know I know there are a lot of
people who want want that kind of like
me to give off some kind of ego like
that but no um obviously I'm nowhere
near the conversation I I actually on
that note I would say also I know people
wanted to know if I'm the greatest
player to never have played for the
world championship or to have not got
not become world champion I don't think
that I'm actually anywhere near the top
of that conversation I actually think
Levon aronian tops that conversation by
a big margin simply because he was
number two in the world for a very very
long time and he never even got to the
match so as far as world champions and
who's the goat I think
um
I think Magnus is the goat simply
because he's playing the best chess
by by a bigger margin as the highest ELO
of all time uh on the other hand chess
is a game where you know you build upon
you build upon the Giants of the past we
learn we learn from them and so you can
definitely make the case for Gary as
well I mean he's the number one player
in the world for 20 plus years a lot of
opening strategies he came up with and
our people still play them today Bobby
I'm not so sure you can really make that
case because he was he shot up really
quickly but he was the world champion
for a very short window of time and then
he he quit the game as soon as he became
world champion so I don't really feel
like you can put Fisher in that uh in
that conversation simply because he
didn't have that longevity at all he was
he was up there for a couple of years so
I would say it's probably Magnus but I
understand people can also say Gary's
Gary's the best player ever
um remains to be seen but I think if
Magnus is number one for probably
another let's say another three to four
years I don't think there's any debate
at all
can you break down what makes him so
good
we've already talked about different
angles of this and I would also
uh try to get the same from you because
we talked about early Hikaru like I'd
like to uh talk about that folder but
first Magnus what makes Magnus so good
what are the various aspects of his game
that make him so good I think for Magnus
he he just you know that in the end game
in the end games if you get there he's
just he's not gonna blunder that's the
first thing so you know if you reach an
end game he's not going to make a
mistake he obviously plays great
openings and there's just really no
defined weakness that he has there's no
weakness that I can think of very
specifically
um many there are many times where
players that actually out prepare him in
the opening phase but as soon as they're
on their own and they have to think very
often times they'll make mistakes
um so there's just no weakness for
Magnus really no weakness well unlike
say Casper like kasparab on the other
hand there there are very clear
weaknesses
um in his game like kramnik exploits on
first of all very I don't want to say
like
ego is the right word but like very
stubborn believing that his openings
were infallible that he could just win
he could just prove an advantage and win
the game out of the opening like against
kramnik when he ultimately lost also
generally not a great defender either
very strong tactically but if he was in
positions that were defensive he would
make mistakes and lose in end games like
he did in one of those games in the
world championship against cram next so
there were very clear defined weaknesses
in Sparrow's game
um whereas like maggots are just they're
no clearly defined weaknesses maybe
maybe he doesn't like being attacked
maybe that's the one thing he likes King
safety and he doesn't like being
attacked but that's not something that
you can easily do whereas say uh if
someone's very tactical and they're not
a strong positionally that is something
you can def that will happen quite
frequently in games you can steer games
a certain way doesn't mean you'll always
get there but that is something tangible
whereas King safety that's not something
tangible at all it's very very hard to
attack someone uh based on unless they
play certain style of openings do you
think Garrick has above
reflecting in your comment would agree
like what is it about his relationship
with with kremnik that was so
challenging I mean I think this is
kramnik understood him actually one
thing that's funny speaking of Kasparov
is that I think it got under her skin
like when I worked with him kramnik
actually played a certain style very
like very aggressive very sort of risky
opening play during the time when I was
when I was working with Gary and I know
that he annoyed Gary because he's like
why couldn't kramnik play like this
against me because I think Gary Felton
did that against him he would have just
blown him off the board and had had many
great victories so I think it's kramnik
understood Gary they had worked together
I think during during the late 90s I
think Gary actually was very useful or
very helpful in terms of cram of getting
a spot on one of the uh Russian chess
Olympiad teams in in the mid 90s so I
think it's just cram understood him very
well and Gary just could not he just he
couldn't figure it out I think also
another thing coming back to Psycho
psychological part is that Kramer
actually beat Kasparov in many games in
the king's Indian defense kasparova
played the king's Indian defense for
many years and they started losing like
four or five games in a row in it to
kramnik very similar to what I mentioned
about the silly night orphan Fabiano and
Gary gave it up he started switching to
playing the grunfeld defense and so I
think that also instilled some
psychological fear as well because Gary
was he was the boss in openings no one
could compare to him
what makes you so good what uh what
What's the breakdown of the strengths
and weaknesses
so that's I think probably my biggest
strength is that I'm a universal player
I can play pretty much any opening
strategy doesn't doesn't really matter
um beyond that I think it's mainly that
I don't really make many blunders I
don't make blunders unless I'm under a
lot of pressure generally so that I mean
I know I'm I'm oversimplifying it's not
as as simple as this does this apply to
uh to Blitz as well I think it's much
more applicable to Blitz in particular
because my intuition is very good so
when I'm making less blunders with
limited time on the clock my opponents
actually make a lot more blunders that
that's why I think it's much more
pronounced in Blitz than it is in
classical chess because in Blitz when
you're down to like 10 seconds uh in the
game both players have 10 seconds my
intuition is just better than theirs I
mean Magnus maybe not so clear but like
if you look at other players say Fabiano
caruan a very strong player when he gets
down to 10 seconds or in these these uh
these situations he almost always makes
a blunder almost always um so I'm just
more precise I make less blunders and
that that's really the the effect is
much more dramatic Blitz what do you
think that intuition is like uh sorry
for the kind of
uh like almost philosophical question
what what is that is that calculation
or is it some kind of weird memory
recall what is that like being able to
do that Short Line
prediction I think that's just playing
so many games online and there's some
kind of subconscious field that I have
because when you're that low on time you
can't calculate it's just you have to
look you just have to figure out what's
the move you want to play as no
calculation and just go with it and I
think just playing so many games
probably I mean I'm guessing I played
over 300 000 games online and I think
just playing all those games it's it's a
feel there's there's no tangible way uh
that I can't put that really into words
it's just a feel what do you Visual and
we should say that you're I think
currently the number one ranked Blitz
player in the world you have uh been for
a while you're unquestionably one of the
greatest so the classical
rapid and Blitz you're one of the best
people for many years in the world okay
but you're currently number one in Blitz
um
so I I'd love to kind of for you to dig
into the secret to your success in Blitz
is it as you're saying that intuition
being able to when the time is short
to not make blunders and then to make a
close to Optimal move I think it's
generally that
I'm able to keep the games going no
matter what until we're low on time I'm
always able to do that yeah like if we
play a game with three minutes like
there are games I will just win win very
quickly but a lot of games between top
players players have to think you have
to use time and in those final critical
stages I just don't blunder I just don't
blunder really at the end of the day
that's that's really the only difference
because everybody's very very strong
but it's sort of like who is the who is
the better like brain who is a better
like CPU or for lack of a better way of
putting it it's like who makes a split
to SEC Split Second decisions the best
and uh I do think that I'm extremely
good at that in a way that almost nobody
else is that that really is the only
difference is that those Split Second
decisions because you can get a worse
position but again if you keep the game
going players have to use a time when
you get down to those final 10 15
seconds uh I almost always end up
winning in those situations what are you
visualizing like when in those when
you're doing the fast fast calculations
what what is it um it's basically you
look at a move and you see like when
it's like five seconds or ten seconds
you play a movie you just make sure that
it's not a blunder you just look make
sure it's not a blunder and you just go
with it and the first part though is the
feel so it's like I see this move and it
looks right I don't know why it's right
I can't put that into words but it looks
like the right move and then I look very
for like a split second see as long as
it's not some kind of blender and you
just play that move is there a bit of a
tunnel vision are you able to understand
the positions of all the other pieces on
the board or are you just focusing on a
very specific interaction it's just Phil
it's really just feel it's like this
move feels right and so I play it when
you're at that stage of the game it's
it's like as long as it's not a blunder
and it just that it's just that feel
there's there is no way for me to put
that in and that feel
like empirically does result in low
probability of blender for you yeah it's
like you don't blunder even though there
could be like you don't forget like a
random piece that was like very very I
mean it does happen of course but very
rarely and I mean I've done it on stream
many times like it's just you you go
with the move that for whatever reason
like it just intuitively whether it's
from playing hundreds of thousands of
games on the internet
um or just that that experience like it
you just intuitively can can feel like
the move is right